there's this great saying that says if
you abuse abandon or neglect the child
the child doesn't stop loving the parent
they stop loving themselves and I think
that's the start of the alarm situation
because when we split from ourselves
when we start judging abandoning blaming
and shaming ourselves as children that
model becomes the way we interact with
life
you get into studying anxiety
well mostly because I suffered from the
damn condition myself for so long you
know I I grew up with a father with
schizophrenia and bipolar illness so my
childhood was more than a bit chaotic so
it was really about trying to understand
what was going on in my own mind because
men typically don't understand what's
going on women are so much better at
explaining their emotions I remember
years ago there was this study that was
done about they put men and women in a
functional MRI scanner and then they
would flash words like compassion
love that kind of and in the women's
Brains like 14 places would light up and
in the men's Brains only four places
would light up so we don't have the
emotional language so much so when I was
younger I didn't really know what
anxiety was until I got into med school
and then it was then it hit me full
force
what was growing up with a bipolar
schizophrenic father-like
well it was really
it was challenging in a lot of ways but
for the first 10 years of my life he was
actually a great dad you know he would
you know teach me how to ride a bike and
hit a ball and he was an award-winning
baseball coach but it the problem was
that every once in a while he would just
lose it and go off and as a child as a
boy with this guy's my hero and then to
see him up all night for four days and
kind of ranting and raving he was never
abusive or violent or anything like that
but it was very destabilizing for me and
I think a lot of my anxiety stemmed from
the fact that
I've studied this since I've been about
16 years old like mental illness and I
because of my dad and I saw that there
was a heritable component to his
schizophrenia and bipolar so I got just
completely freaked out so what I would
do is I would say okay if you make it to
25 and you don't show up with
schizophrenia you're probably fine then
it was 30 then it was 35. so once I get
to 35 it's like okay I think I missed
the gene for that but I think I
developed anxiety because I saw him
suffer so much and go to Mental
Hospitals and and just really really be
in in bad bad shape and I just thought I
don't want to be like that like I don't
want to I don't want that to be my life
why would seeing your dad in that way
create a foundation for anxiety
I think you know if you look at the the
neurochemistry of it like we have these
prefrontal cortices so I did a degree in
medicine at a degree in Neuroscience so
I I tried it and blend the Neuroscience
with the emotional stuff being a
clinician as well
so when you're raised in a stressful
environment as a child there's these
cells in our prefrontal cortex and our
prefrontal cortex you know is executive
function mem helps our memory it helps
us really understand and formulate the
world
and these pyramidal cells don't evolve
that well or don't grow or metabolize
very well in chronic trauma with kids
what does unfortunately get honed into
US is these subcortical these areas
below the cortex below our awareness
like the amygdala it grows fibers that
go right through the brain and and it's
dendrites go really really they get very
very sensitized to any form of
norepinephrine dopamine even dopamine
which is a positive you know everyone
thinks it's positive but it really can't
overwhelm our brains so I think what
happens is that we get this overwhelm
when we have trauma as children and
instead of you know maturing the
prefrontal cortex and making us more
able to roll with the punches and handle
stress we we kind of supercharge the the
subcortical areas the basal ganglia the
parts of us that kind of are automatic
the parts of us that would sort of fall
prey to addiction that sort of grows in
us and the prefrontal cortex doesn't so
we don't we don't have the neurological
ability to really regulate stress when
there's trauma as children now there's
more to it than that but it's basically
shortening it quite a bit does that mean
then that people who perhaps went
through trauma as children would have a
greater predisposition to Compulsive
phone use in later life because they're
more sensitive dopaminergically which
means that it's going to be easier for
apps and Technology to trigger that
yeah I think any kind of addiction you
know because it does form a bit of when
you're anxious when you have a tendency
towards anxiety sort of overthinking so
what we do is we escape into our heads
and we ruminate and we just keep going
there and I think this is sort of
jumping ahead a bit but I think we
actually store trauma in our bodies as
well
so when you're a child and something
happens to you that you can't control or
is is terrible for you
you push that down Freud would call it
repression so we push it down into the
subcortical structures the unconscious
structures and those structures are also
involved specifically the basal ganglia
in movement and our body so I think we
stuff this trauma down into our body and
rather than feel it in our body we go up
into our heads and that's another reason
why I think trauma in childhood makes us
more likely to be addicted in adulthood
because these old circuits have been
revved up for us these addictive
circuits rather than going into that
place of you know calm and peace in our
prefrontal cortex we automatically
gravitate to sort of pain relief rather
than just allowing what's happening in
life to happen like people with anxiety
compulsively hate uncertainty and they
will do anything to avoid uncertainty
and that includes worry so people say
well worry does nothing actually worry
does quite a bit worry is a major
distractor from this old alarm if you
have trauma especially as a child
where would the human physiology store
anxiety in the body yeah what does that
mean it's a great question you know and
my colleague Gabor mate talks about this
too you know it's really hard to divide
the mind and the body like it's it's an
academic kind of distinction between the
two there's a part of our brain called
the insular cortex and the insular
cortex is kind of like the mediator
between the mind and the body so the
mind has an idea it gets sort of
translated into bodily Sensations those
bodily Sensations also come up through
the insula and get translated into into
thoughts and processes so I believe that
when we're young and we have a trauma
that's too much for us to bear that
insular cortex
records the bodily sensations of that
trauma so for me in my book I talk about
how I store my trauma in my solar plexus
and I only found this because I did LSD
you know there was a point in 2013 where
I you know I didn't feel like life was
worth living anymore if I had to live in
a 10 hour panic attack every day
so a friend of mine took me on a trip
through LSD and on LSD one's all the
lights and disorientation stopped I got
this message and I still don't know
where it's from that my anxiety what I
called my anxiety was actually a state
of alarm that was held in my body from
this old trauma of growing up with a
schizophrenic father
so I devoted the book and my own healing
into okay if this alarm is in my body
how do I bring this out how do I find it
because I do believe that that alarm is
a version of my younger self
I believe that when we get traumatized
as children part of us stay stuck in
that trauma for the rest of our lives
and I think the insula has something to
do with that Superior temporal gyrus I
think there's a lot of pre or
subcortical
circuits that get engaged and reinforced
as children and that body Sensation that
you feel now when you're anxious quote
unquote anxious or I like to call
alarmed is probably the exact same
feeling that you had when you're going
home from school and you didn't know if
your mum was going to be drunk or your
dad was going to abuse you or whatever
it's probably the exact same feeling now
that you felt back then and this is
where kind of the amygdala comes into
because the amygdala has no sense of
time
so when we record trauma through the
amygdala because the amygdala never
forgets and it remembers everything that
ever hurt you so we record that we don't
know if it's in the body if it's in the
mind it becomes this philosophical
argument so it's it's kind of a
construct that I use with people saying
okay this trauma is stored in your body
where do you find it some people find it
in their throat other people fight at
their chest or for me it's in my solar
plexus
strangely enough I see patterns with
people like people had to grow up too
fast and look after their family they
feel it across their shoulders or women
especially who grow up with a
narcissistic or overly demanding mother
have it in their throat like these are
little things after dealing with
hundreds and hundreds of people with
anxiety I see these little alarm
patterns with people and then I believe
that alarm pattern is your younger self
asking for your attention and I you know
Andrew huberman talks about grief being
a motivational State I believe that
anxiety is also a motivational State
it's motivating you to connect with that
younger part of you that got traumatized
and that trauma never got resolved but
the problem is what we do is we go into
our heads and we start worrying and
ruminating which actually gives us more
of the problem so I didn't start healing
until I started going okay and for a
neuroscientist a medical doctor to start
going into your body because it sounds
so woo and it sounds so so out there but
it's really after 30 years of you know
EMDR or CBT psychotic therapy it's the
only thing that really made a real
difference for me is going into my body
as well as using cognitive therapies as
well so you need both and I see in our
society we worship the mind so much that
we believe that these that the mind can
heal the mind and I think huberman said
that as well we can't use the mind to
heal the mind we need the body to come
along and I think that's that's the
Folly of a lot of
cognitive therapies as they believe that
if we just change your thinking you'll
change your feeling and what I like to
say is you can't feel your way out of a
thinking or you can't think your way out
of a feeling problem
why do you think the current modern
world seems to be played with anxiety is
it concept creep are people using the
word anxiety to refer to something which
isn't anxiety have we got a
preponderance of this due to Detachment
from nature too much time in technology
poor sleep and wake Cycles blah blah
blah like how do you see the
contribution to this all that stuff I
mean I think
um I've done a lot of work in
developmental psychology with uh Gordon
neufeld who wrote a book called uh hold
on to your kids with gabarmate
and he says that all anxiety is
separation anxiety and I add on to that
and it's mostly separation from yourself
because what I think happens is when
we're children and most of chronic
anxiety starts in childhood not
everything is trauma but it certainly
plays a role and I think there is just
more trauma in the world so I believe
that something happens to us as as
children that we can't handle
that gets repressed down as Freud would
call it into our subconscious mind into
these subcortical structures and as the
body is a representation of the
unconscious mind we can find these
traumas in our body if we look for them
and I think there is so much separation
in the world now if you look at U.S
politics it's a great example of us and
their mentality and when we get stressed
when we start secreting norepinephrine
and adrenaline we start looking for
certainty especially if you have trauma
as a child but in general human beings
start looking for certainty so this us
that mentality if you're not with me
you're against me really flourishes
which increases the separation which
increases the global sense of anxiety
because all anxiety truly is separation
anxiety and it's mostly separation from
yourself because just to take it a
little further I think what happens is
when we get traumatized as children
we split from ourselves because we have
these parents and we can't see them as
as at fault because they're looking
after us so the only person left to
blame is yourself there's this great
saying that says if you abuse abandon or
neglect the child the child doesn't stop
loving the parent they stop loving
themselves
and I think that's the start of the
alarm situation because when we split
from ourselves when we start judging
abandoning blaming and shaming ourselves
what I call Jabs when we start taking
Jabs at ourselves as children
that model becomes the way we interact
with life in general
so we have this or you could also call
it the inner critic we have this inner
critic that's chronically keeping us off
balance and separate from ourselves and
while we're separate from ourselves
that's when anxiety just thrives it
seems like I had Jessica Baum on the
show she wrote anxiously attached yeah
and that was interesting you know
attachment theories kind of uh trendy at
the moment I suppose uh and learning
about how
patterns that you learn to cope with
discomfort as a child are
modeling perhaps for uh the way that you
will cope with that in future so when
you get into a relationship with
somebody that's not a million miles away
from a tight close personal relationship
that you might have had with a parent
and then if you have fears of
Abandonment because that may have been
the way that you were made to be quiet
as a child or whatever it might be uh
that those will start to come back up
it is beginning for me to
press over the line away from
evidence-based and like you said before
like into the woo and it seems like
straddling the line between those two is
uh kind of a delicate one I'm
hyper attuned like my woo radar is so
sensitive so for me to be I I got that I
understood from Jessica and I understand
why it would be the case from you but
moving it a little bit further forward
into uh the the stress or the the
anxieties held in the shoulders and it's
attached with this and it's held in the
chest and it's attached with this that
Verge is closer toward like horoscope
stuff for me oh yeah and oh for sure
that is where
um I imagine that there'll be some
people that go ah you know this just
this doesn't seem a little bit
evidence-based enough and yet you're
somebody that's gone through whatever
like two three degrees three decades of
of learning about this stuff and this is
where you've arrived like do you write
it back to yeah yeah do you do you feel
inside of yourself a little bit of a
contradiction at all or or the the
evidence-based medical side of you
um coming into conflict with the the
more holistic side of you absolutely
yeah and this is this is part
of the whole
you know separation of Mind and Body
which is really at the heart of what
anxiety really is is we get this
mind-body separation
and yeah it's been hard for me because
if you look at neuroscience and even
Joseph Ledoux who's a you know a Pioneer
in Neuroscience hardcore Neuroscience he
wrote this book called anxious that I
love that I've read five times and still
don't understand
but but basically he says that you know
despite these tremendous advances we've
made in Neuroscience in the last 20
years it really hasn't moved into the
clinical realm very much really
Psychotherapy healing therapy is really
this connection between the therapist
and the client patient whatever you want
to call it and that we really can't
explain scientifically we can go through
you know prefrontal cortex pyramidal
cells bed nucleus of the striat
terminalis being kind of maybe at the
heart of worry at the heart of like
rumination and that kind of stuff but
how does that transpose into clinical
help clinical work so I think that's
where we're kind of stuck these days is
we we have this urge like I was saying
just a few minutes ago we have this urge
for certainty and when we look at stuff
like evidence-based
what has that really done like I look at
it like what is evidence-based stuff
really done for emotional healing or
what is science really done from it it's
shown us the pathways it's shown us the
places in the in the brain that sort of
light up with these different things but
it hasn't really translated into actual
practical you know work to help people
heal so that's where that's why I get
kind of thrown off balance a little bit
is like what does science got to do with
emotional healing not a lot from what I
found you know I've done the the cbts
I've done a lot of the the the uh the
evidence-based work and it really didn't
do much for me and I get messages from
people every day going I did CBT for two
years and it didn't you know it helps
and I think a lot of the cognitive stuff
what I found with my own healing is that
once I did the
inner work once I did the connection
with myself these cognitive things
started to make sense to me as I came
out as I as I started to heal but going
into healing I found that it really was
this kind of connection I had with my
therapist connection I had with myself
just really really connecting with
myself and of course as a medical doctor
and neuroscientist this does sound very
rude to me and it's very uncomfortable
for me to go on a big podcast like yours
and say that anxiety is held in the body
more than the mind
because it it really goes against my my
traditional allopathic medical training
but in my experience with my my clients
patients and myself it's really been the
thing that that's held Sway and helped
me heal is developing this connection
with myself using the alarm sensation in
my body to perhaps reverse engineer
getting into those unconscious programs
that started when I was very young and
being able to change them around a bit
because trying to use the conscious mind
to change these unconscious subcortical
basal ganglia programs is virtually
impossible now we can use the prefrontal
cortex and that can help us move as
we're getting through it but it's not as
I see a mechanism a mechanism for
healing in and of itself so I think we
need some sort of somatic approach mixed
with the cognitive evidence-based stuff
before we really start to heal or at
least that's been the case with me that
makes sense one of the things that I've
got in the back of my mind is if we have
had these particular Pathways laid down
for so long 20 30 40 50 years in some
cases uh they are so deep that you can't
access them consciously they have been
reinforced you know that myelin is is
[ __ ] it it's down there right like it in
and I think I'm right in saying that you
can't ever break existing myelin sheaths
you can only overload overlay new
thought patterns is that right yeah I
mean I think that you know there's so
much about the brain we don't understand
but I think that's true and I think you
know using the amygdala as an example
the amygdala remembers everything now
people will tell me all the time as a
child I don't remember I don't have any
childhood memories I can't remember and
I say to them a lot I said no you have
memories you're just not able to
retrieve them because the part of our
our brain that retrieves memories is
prefrontal and if we if we lose access
to that prefrontal cortex we lose access
to the ability to remember so one of the
ironic things is that I will drag people
into their into their alarm slowly and
I'll titrate them so say someone will
have this alarm in their throat I'll say
okay just close your eyes you know
ground yourself in your body feel your
butt in the chair relax your shoulders
relax your jaw
now let's go into this feeling
you know just bring up a bring up a
Trauma from your past don't pick the
worst trauma of your life but pick a
Trauma from your past that perhaps still
bothers you
keep your jaw relaxed keep your
shoulders relaxed
just stay present with that and in your
mind's eye just see if you can go into
the the is-ness of that feeling
now is there a place in your body
it kind of lights up that maybe it's an
ache or a pain or there's a pressure
sensation
and then I'll get them to find that area
of alarm in their body
and then once we find that alarm for me
like I said it's in my solar plexus
put your hand over it kind of breathe
into it allow it to be there
because I do believe and this is where
it gets really woo that that sensation
of alarm is your younger self
it is something what do you mean when
you say that when you say it is your
younger self I think there's an aspect
of our younger self that gets encoded
into our body now maybe that's through
the insular cortex you know maybe it's
through the basal ganglia the movement
system but I believe that's a part of
that trauma that goes into our body and
gets held there and perhaps what happens
is there's too much energy for that
child to hold it so it gets repressed
into the unconscious mind and as Bessel
Vandercook talks about on the body keeps
the score the the mind is is represented
by the body
so if there's a representation of your
body in your unconscious mind we can use
that sensation in your body to kind of
reverse engineer and go back one step
and find those programs in your
unconscious mind and this is the basis
of hakomi somatic experiencing that kind
of like somatic kind of therapy
and I think when we do that when we see
that alarm and we're able to find that
younger version of ourselves like
sometimes what I'll do is I'll say do
you have a picture of yourself when your
parents divorced around the age and then
I'll get them to put that that picture
up behind their mirror and talk to that
picture and this is again it's getting
really woo right so you talk to that
picture and then you look at yourself in
the mirror and you talk to yourself in
your present day term because that child
because the amygdala has no sense of
time is still stuck there
so when you show that child that they're
not stuck there you bring them into
engagement present day engagement and
then you look at yourself showing that
child that you are actually this 38 48
58 year old person and then go back to
the child and this is mirror work this
is really difficult for people to do
but it really makes a huge difference
it's one of the modalities that I use
with my patients that really helps them
show that child that they're not stuck
back there anymore because there's part
of the amygdala that when we get into
alarm
or anxiety that gets transported back to
that same place and time that that
trauma was occurring is that what you
call the alarm anxiety cycle absolutely
so what will happen is so we'll feel
this alarm in our system say we get
stressed like we're doing okay in
general and then we have a breakup or
whatever so that alarm will light up in
our system now the brain through this
process called enteroception which
you've probably heard of before is
constantly reading your internal and
external environment so it reads this
alarm that's in our system and because
the alarm is disquieting and painful and
uncomfortable the mind being a
compulsive meaning making makes sense
machine has to do something with that so
it makes up worries it makes up these
you know what ifs worries warnings all
these things that make sense of this
alarm this is mostly subconscious below
your level of Consciousness and you're
just doing it automatically and then you
blame the worries for the pain but it
wasn't the worries the worries of the
byproduct of the pain the pain is
actually this alarm that's been stored
in you since you were a child and then
when you when you think those worries
the alarm gets worse the alarm gets
aggravated which of course makes the
worries worse and on top of that we
start creating cortisol and epinephrine
in our system norepinephrine in the
brain
and that paralyzes the rational parts of
our mind you know Patricia Goldman rakik
um
out of Yale University did this study
that showed that when we're stressed
that we shut off the prefrontal cortex
so we go we fall back into these
emotional subcortical areas so if we
have an addiction you know if we have
something that that is really powerfully
emotionally negative that we encoded as
a child we will fall back into that
because our prefrontal cortex has been
Paralyzed by Dope by the catecholamines
dopamine norepinephrine uh and basically
what happens is we fall back into this
Old State which I believe is a remnant
of our younger self
so to heal that we have to go back and
find that younger self and show them
that they're not back there anymore so
a little while ago I did something that
was like a a big job and it was like I
knew that it was there was a lot of
pressure and everything was going great
and then part way through
um I realized that my blood sugar was
dropping so I'm sat down I'm having this
conversation my blood sugar is falling
through the floor and as I'm doing it uh
this sort of inner monologue comes up
and I've done a good bit of self work
over the last few years right so I I had
got myself to a stage where my inner
voice is significantly better than it
was still got a lot of work to do but
significantly better than it was it was
pretty it was pretty toxic it was pretty
nasty sure and uh I'm part way through
this thing and as my mind goes blank
because I've run out of blood sugar uh
this voice comes out of nowhere and it
starts saying you were never supposed to
be here you know that you flute this
you're boring no one cares about what
you've got to say uh you don't deserve
this everybody's gonna laugh at you
nobody likes you you're going to be
found out you've always been a fraud you
are a fraud and I was like whoa whoa
whoa where are you coming from like
who's this uh and as I'm sat there in
this sort of voices going on in the back
of my head thankfully because I've done
whatever like
thousands of hours of this stuff I was
able to carry through pretty much on
um the same ways you can drive and have
an argument with your partner at the
same time right like the driving doesn't
take up that much energy my performance
probably wouldn't have been so good as
if I'd been able to be present but my
point being that I was able to keep
going and it literally wouldn't normally
have even noticed right no one in the
room even noticed what was going on uh
however in the back of my mind I had
this and I was like I reflected on it a
lot it was really sort of profound uh
thing to happen to me it's the first
time that it's happened in quite a while
uh and I'd convince myself that I'd got
rid of a lot of whatever that is you
know the voice of a critical teacher
critical parent critical friend like
whoever that was
um
I'd convince myself that that didn't
exist anymore and then what I realized
was that Maybe
under situations of intense uh pressure
stress gravity
um
there is a
recession receding
um there is a retreat back into not
something that necessarily feels
comfortable but something that feels
familiar and one of the most familiar
things that I think I can remember is
having this really negative critical
toxic awful inner voice and I thought oh
still there sometimes
yeah and I think you know this is where
kind of psychedelics come into because
you know people that have done
psychedelics will see that critical
inner voice because what psychedelics do
is they they separate the conscious or
they the separation from the conscious
of the unconscious is now gone so the
conscience and the unconscious are
basically and the separation from us and
our environment goes away too
now there's an area in your brain called
the anterior cingulate cortex now that
area is is
bolstered up by meditation they found
and it has a mediating influence on the
amygdala so this is why they think maybe
meditation helps so I think the work
that you've done has kind of maybe maybe
bolstered up this area interior single
cortex and that's kind of calm your
amygdala which allowed you to have the
Curiosity the luxury of curiosity
because usually when we get stressed
like that we're not curious we're it
we're in it you know and there's another
part of our brain called the posterior
cingulate cortex that's around the same
area that they think may have something
to do with self-referential thought so
when you're saying these negative things
about yourself that may God been encoded
in you long long ago and the posterior
singlet is part of that default mode
Network so when we go when our brains
aren't actively focused on a task we
fall back into this default mode Network
and if there's a lot of this negative
energy sitting in there that we haven't
metabolized or we haven't worked through
it'll come up so that's why when we get
stressed we get kicked you know in the
balls when we when we need it the most
when we need that that energy the most
we go into those subcortical structure
structures we fall out of our prefrontal
cortex and we fall down into basal
ganglia we fall down into the amygdal
these unconscious programs that were put
into us when we're children and if that
if you had significant childhood trauma
that Groove that that's a 12-lane super
highway that goes right into the
negative and then of course the negative
thoughts go and then we do this process
called stacking
um I coined this term called stacking
which is basically when you're when your
body's alarmed when your system is
alarmed you start thinking oh I've got
this taxes oh my son's not doing well oh
and the money's coming up this like we
stack things because they have the same
kind of resonance with how we're feeling
so it's very it's very difficult to
think in opposition to how your body
feels which is why why positive
psychology is is a lot of work like it's
it's like if your brain all of a sudden
decided that you had to consciously
breathe every time you know you you
can't just keep up that positive feeling
or that positive thinking all the time
because it's exhausting you wouldn't be
able to do anything else so as huberman
says you know we can use the body
to to calm the mind and in fact the body
is a much better facilitator of calming
the Mind than the mind is a facilitator
of calming the body so I think that's
where I think a lot of the somatic work
is is going my wife's a somatic trauma
therapist so we're talking all the time
about how do we use the body to kind of
bring people back into their prefrontal
cortex to bring them back into present
day and one of the ways we do that is
sensation you know I have this thing
where I get people to cross their
fingers across their wrists across the
midline and then rub their face now it
looks very creepy it looks very it's
really weird it does it does so if
you're on your own don't do this at the
grocery store but if you're on your own
it's one of those things that if you
look at the somatosensory strip so much
of our brain the motor and sensory
cortex is devoted to our hands and our
face so if we do if we put our hands on
our face we have to come into sensation
we have to come into present moment
sensation because the brain just can't
ignore that there's too much and when we
come into sensation present moment
sensation a lot of those worries because
all worries about the future all worries
about the future so as soon as you bring
yourself into the sensation of the
present moment immediately you'll feel
better
thinking about
the cycle that you go through and where
it ends up in the mind
what's the reason that we want to
explain whatever the problem is is this
just closing the loop is this just that
we have an aversion to uncertainty is
that really absolutely yeah you nailed
it you nailed it we have human beings
have a fundamental dislike of
uncertainty you know we have this fear
bias that we're born with from an
evolutionary perspective it kept us
alive thousands and thousands of years
ago this fear of bias now unfortunately
we have stone age you know we still have
a stone age brain in a digital world so
we still react like we would thousands
of years ago so it's a matter of being
able to tolerate uncertainty and that's
what a lot of anxiety healing comes from
is being able to tolerate the fact that
this is uncertain and in fact I use some
of Kyle sees's work and I say this is
uncertain and I love that you know if
you have a medical test or whatever this
is uncertainty so a lot of what worry
does is it kind of makes the uncertain a
little more certain so if you have a
headache and you think oh it must be a
brain tumor now you've taken this sort
of global headache sensation and you've
really specifically put it into a
category that that makes sense and then
you've you've lowered the uncertainty
someone and this is one of the I think
this is one of the reasons why we worry
so much is because worry for that
fraction of a second you know that's all
we need for the amygdalas is that
fraction of a second it provides us with
a sense of relief now when we believe
that we have a brain tumor of course the
alarm gets worse again and then we have
to redouble our efforts to kind of worry
to keep us in our head so we avoid
feeling that alarm sensation that's
stuck in our body
so and again you know it it's it's a
construct you know we can't separate the
body from the mind but it certainly
helps a lot of my anxiety patients to
realize hey what if this is in the body
how can we handle this because anxiety
and uncertainty basically go together so
when we explain and it makes sense to us
you know and this is where the
confirmation bias comes from when it
when we explain something we're going to
explain it in ways we already understand
so if we if we've been anxious all our
lives we're going to explain the worry
you know in a framework we understand
and it's a familiar friend in a way
worry so that's one of the hardest
things that I have about helping people
resolve anxiety is they look at that
hyper vigilance that chronic need for
certainty as protective so if I take
that away from you and I say hey let's
start really looking at how you create
uncertainty in your life and how you can
you can Embrace that uncertainty like
really make make the intention to
embrace the uncertainty and all you know
immediately that helps people feel
better rather than going into it so if
you have two roads to go one is
embracing the uncertainty and the other
is worry start going into the you know
embracing uncertainty
you mentioned earlier on about some of
the potential issues that men have when
it comes to understanding and voicing
emotions right is there anything
interesting or different about the ways
that anxiety manifests for men versus
women yeah I think that women have much
more of an emotional language so they
can they can get a sense of it like
what's happening with them they are much
more of an emotional intelligence in a
way
then it often shows up in Anger
antagonism
annoyance you know I have the man m-a-n
manoance antagonism manger anxiety you
know so like me when I was you know
heading into med school and I felt this
you know depersonalization derealization
all that kind of stuff I was like what
the [ __ ] is happening to me
and the only thing I could go back to is
is just you know my breath and and just
kind of trying to Center myself as best
I could but it was a losing battle
because I was in this this fight with
anxiety like I I had this imposter
syndrome as well like can I get through
medical school like did they make a
mistake when they admitted me to medical
school all that kind of stuff so it was
it is one of those things that I think
that we look at uncertainty and we look
at our lives in this framework from our
chart from our childhood
and to to move away from that is
basically what we need to do to heal but
there is that familiarity in that
uncertainty that we kind of keep going
back to we're in a way we're addicted to
uncertainty and and we continue to
create it so you see people who pick the
same Partners over and over again you
know my last partner was you know
abusive or whatever it's like why do you
keep picking the same person like the
same person different haircut like why
is this happening so and I find a lot of
people get into these intense
relationships and the relationship is so
intense at the start because both of
them are reactivating their own
childhood wounding you know and that's
why it's so that's why it's so
passionate so I don't know if I answered
your question there kind of went off a
little bit but uh I had the director of
relationship science from hinge Logan
Yuri on the show she was fascinating and
um she talked about Sparks in
relationships and she mentioned that a
lot of the time people kind of look for
the spark perhaps it's I don't know
given to us through media through Disney
movies and stuff like that or perhaps
it's just some archaic Renaissance sense
of what romance is supposed to be
um and sometimes people have a concern
that they don't find a spark with the
person that they're with and she really
blew my mind because she says people
don't understand that some other people
are just Sparky everybody around them
feels like that that check out cashier
feels like that the mechanic feels like
that the person that serves them the
Starbucks feels like that their partner
feels like that their parents feel like
that they're just able to induce spark
in other people but that doesn't
necessarily mean that they are any more
or less appropriate for you as a
long-term partner and Spark a lot of the
time I think comes can come from
conflict you know there is
this belief that
passion should rear its head in a number
of different ways and I certainly know
that I have a relatively peaceful
disposition which has wound up some
ex-girlfriends because if something
that they feel like I should be riled up
about and and should kick off about
doesn't elicit a response from me what
they see that as is I mean not caring
enough just to kind of round off what
you said at the very beginning about the
men and women thing have you got any
idea how much of that is restricted by
culture
and how much of that is a biological
heritable
um sex split with regards to the
fundamental capabilities of men and
women you've mentioned that women seem
to have a greater capacity for emotional
like linguistic rationality uh
understanding they're able to do those
terms how much of that have you got any
idea about whether or not that's
something that's embedded within us it's
hard you know it's really hard to tell I
think men kind of police ourselves when
we're younger you know you don't cry
when you're hurt you know and I think
that that really starts forming a
pattern of behavior and then you add
into that the comp the natural
competition that men have with each
other which I believe is evolutionary
like you you compete and then the you
know it used to be the strongest got the
mate and procreate the species now I
think that it creates this environment
among men where they can't talk about
their vulnerability
and I think there is a difference
between victimhood and vulnerability and
I think men they kind of get turned off
by both but I think it's they're they're
more likely to accept someone who's
being vulnerable you know like if I said
to my friend hey you know what I'm
really having a problem with my wife
right now like I don't know if we're
gonna make it it's really it's really
hurting me like it's really troubling me
man another man will take that 100 times
over me going oh I don't know what's
happening like she's not we're not
having sex anymore or nothing like there
is that kind of the difference between
victim and vulnerability and I think
that's what we're wrestling with as men
right now because women are saying we
want our men to be more vulnerable it's
like well do you you know you look at
you know Rolo to Massey's work and that
kind of thing about how you don't show
vulnerability to your to your wife you
don't show vulnerability to your
girlfriend and it really is that fine
line that dance between okay how much of
this is vulnerable and how much of it is
Victim Because I think victim turns
everybody off and and we're vulnerable
is kind of like okay we can kind of
access that so I think men
um just don't know how to do either
really we don't know how to be
vulnerable because the whole thing gets
fired into the same trash can of like no
I can't show weakness because men see
sharing emotions as a weakness
and I know now I'm 62 now I'll be 62 in
a few days and it's like I'm really able
to tell my male friends hey you know
what I love you you know you've been
great for me you know I love what you I
love the influence you have in my life
where I was 30 there's no way I could
have done that you know and I think I
don't know what the change is uh as we
get older I think we just start seeing
this sort of kind of BS competitive
mentality that we have with other men
and we're already struggling as men
we're already kind of second-class
citizens in the world right now the way
the pendulum is swinging you know and we
look at you know Mass Shooters are men
rapists are men like you know um the
patriarchy all this kind of stuff and I
think in general you know we're all
suffering I mean everyone's suffered men
women we're all suffering and I think
men just assume that everyone else is
suffering and just like well I gotta
suck it up this is the way I've been
conditioned
um I don't have the emotional language
to be able to express this in a way
that's going to get me the reaction that
I want and a lot of times like when you
when I because a lot of my male friends
through the years have always kind of
come to me I'm kind of like the guy on
the road trips that everybody comes to
when they're having problems with their
wives with their girlfriend and it's
hard for them to share because they
don't have the language for it they know
the emotion is in them and I try and say
well can you just get in touch with that
emotion Can You Feel That Emotion in
your body and allow it to be there and
allow it to process rather than going
into our heads because if you look at
some of the studies you know men are
much more likely to kill themselves
they're much more likely to use alcohol
they're much more likely to to become
violent and I think that's all sort of
you know pushing off the energy of just
this angst that we have that we can't
relate with each other
and it's really can we develop this this
relationship with each other that it's
like okay we're all suffering right now
we're all and in a way I look at the the
sort of the the backlash against men as
a way that we can use to kind of come
together in a way and can you find this
vulnerability in you and can you be able
to share it because you know Lisa
Feldman Barrett wrote this book called
how emotions are made and she talks
about you know just how men and women
fundamentally don't understand emotion
and how men just kind of they don't have
the emotion words and there's also this
evidence that the more emotion words you
know
um the more emotionally intelligent you
become and Men typically aren't that
great at emotion words you know we have
like the seven basic emotions and that's
kind of what we stick with because I
think we've been policed like I said by
other men for our whole lives there is a
certain code of conduct that you you
have as a male and and being vulnerable
or sharing really isn't in that code of
conduct the other thing the last thing
I'll put into this is you know it's
really frowned upon for men to have
tears and one of the things that Gordon
neufeld my developmental psychology Guru
talks about is like tears are adaptive
tears help the brain resolve issues that
you can't resolve so if you're getting a
divorce or if your pets just died or
whatever you can't change that like you
there's there's things you can't change
so what women do is they cry and it
changes the brain
brain derived growth factor it creates
all these ways that we can resolve it
but men can't we shut off our ability to
cry which basically shuts off our
ability to manage you know big emotions
to manage big energy and then it gets
shoved into alcohol abuse porn
um you know ex violence you know that's
the way it's got to go somewhere the
Energy's got to go somewhere
how many people
potentially especially men but people
overall do you think are chronically
anxious and are giving it a different
term yeah saying I'm always stressed all
the time or I'm always tired all the
time I'm always angry or frustrated all
the time
um
how much of that do you think is that
and how much of that do you think could
be explained by anxiety
well I mean exact I love to use the term
alarm rather than anxiety because that's
what I I think that's what it is it's a
state of alarm in our system and the
anxiety is just the byproduct the
anxiety is just our mind's way of kind
of taking this alarm through
interception and going I'm going to make
sense of this alarm by making a worry
about it so I think there's you know we
all have anxiety like anxiety is just a
part of of life in general but when you
have chronic anxiety when you're
chronically worried when your amygdala
is chronically firing
it creates a lot of problems because you
will start seeing the World Through The
Eyes of threat because that's what it
does like when you create epinephrine
and cortisol in your system your brain
from an evolutionary perspective starts
to preferentially look for threat and if
there's no threat in your environment if
you're just lying there with your covers
tucked up to your chin and there's no
threat in your environment you will make
one up and that's where worry and you I
heard you talk about this in one of your
podcasts about you know your episodes of
depression you know where you just you
can't even get to the shower I've been
there I know exactly what that feels
like and that paralysis you know it
comes from just not being able to
metabolize typically old trauma not that
everything is childhood trauma but you
know most 90 of the people that I see
their anxiety results from childhood
trauma so it's being able to understand
that being able to connect with yourself
rather than split with yourself and just
understand how the brain and the body
work to be able to kind of metabolize
some of that trauma allow the
uncertainty embrace the uncertainty
allow it to be there breathe through it
you know
um huberman's thing about the
physiological Psy you know just the two
steps in
and then long slow breath out now with
my anxiety peeps this is what I do with
them I I get them to do it three times
because there's the alveoli that humor
would explain really beautifully about
the size of a tennis court if you
stretched out the the surface area of
the lungs now what I get them to do
because classically with anxiety what
people do is they start slowly slowly
slowly breathing shallower and shallower
and shallower and that sends a message
up to your brain stem like Hey we're in
danger
so what I do with people is I take get
them to take three big sniffs in like
and then hold it at the top
three to five seconds and then close
your teeth
[Music]
and breathe out and while you make that
hissing sound through your teeth
you you just imagine like an over
inflated Tire just kind of collapsing
again and I do this for people that have
white coat syndrome with blood pressure
you know I walk up to them I take their
blood pressure it's Sky High because the
doctor's taking their blood pressure I
do a few rounds of this and their blood
pressure comes down like sometimes 50 or
60 points
so it really is something
that I've added on to the physiological
side so three three breaths into your
nose
really deep
opens up the alveoli
and then you you almost load the CO2 by
holding your breath and then you blow it
out
and that if I do that too many times my
I'll start zoning out because this is
what I use to kind of calm myself but it
really really works like it's really
really helpful and also it gives people
a sense there's something they can do
you know there because the thing about
anxiety is you never know when it's
going to end I remember in 2013 when I
ruptured my left Achilles tendon and I
was suicidal because I was in I was in a
12 hour panic attack every day like
every single day and I thought and this
is where my friend took me on the LSD
trip because I was just thinking you
went on an LSD trip whilst you were
still in your moon boot from a ruptured
Achilles yeah
foreign
well so I ruptured mine two years ago
but I didn't I didn't take a ton of
psychedelics and lie on the couch or
maybe I should have done that the
recovery would have gone quicker well
I'm not
I'm not here's the thing like people say
do you you need to take psychedelics to
heal it's like no you know actually with
anxiety I think psychedelics and on some
level are contraindicated because
anxiety is about trying to maintain
control of your environment right and
then as soon as you take psilocybin
Ayahuasca LSD
um any of this any of the uh
psychedelics you're blown apart you know
so it took me about two years to recover
from Ayahuasca so from 2013 to 2015 I
was getting up every day at like one
o'clock in the afternoon barely eating I
lost like 30 pounds like I'm I'm
normally about 180 if I'm in fight in
shape and I went down to 153.
you know and it's just you know just the
way that your your body can work against
you what was going on there were you
struggling to integrate what was
happening yes yes and and my anxiety
actually got worse but I had this gift
of saying okay start working on this you
know this sense of alarm in your body
start working on this place in your
solar plexus and and slowly over the
course of time I started realizing that
that place in my solar plexus was the
the child in me was the boy in me
that didn't get seen heard loved and
protected like he needed so you know to
go into the woo atmosphere a little bit
it's like I had to see hear love and
protect that child you know that was
watching his dad be taken away to the
mental hospital like I had to find him
and that's really that really began my
healing journey and I think that that
that's really understated because we we
use the mind so much in Psychotherapy
and that kind of thing we believe the
mind can heal the mind and it can to
some extent but you also need this
somatic focus and you also need to focus
on yourself especially if you had trauma
as a kid because you separate as I was
saying earlier you separate from your
own self and that's also all anxiety is
separation anxiety so we separate from
ourselves and that's what creates the
alarm so to to to relieve the alarm what
we need to do is reconnect with
ourselves that makes perfect sense and
Bessel vanderkle talks about that too
you know he says you know we're not
teaching people how to get rid of their
anxiety
or basically teaching you how to
acclimatize to that sensation so that
you don't relentlessly and compulsively
add thoughts to it because then you get
caught in that alarm anxiety cycle that
you can't get out of because you can't
see and I love the saying you can't see
the label from inside the bottle because
that's exactly what it is when you're
anxious your prefrontal cortex your
ability to kind of be curious and see is
gone so all you are the anxiety and
people who have anxiety know exactly
what I'm talking about
I understand what we're talking about
here to do with the state changes that
we could go through thinking about how
it feels within the body maybe doing
some sort of breath work perhaps getting
outside into nature some fresh sunlight
into the eyes some fresh air looking up
through trees at chaotic patterns you
know a bunch of rejuvenative practices
that may be able to help people to get
out of what it is they're doing when it
comes to going from state to trait over
time when it comes to trying to make a
real lasting impact to
ingrained anxious patterns what moves
the needle the most in your experience
I think a combination of somatic therapy
and probably internal family systems
work
you know Parts work you're going to have
to explain what both of those things
mean okay so somatic experiencing is is
a a motive therapy invented by Dr Peter
Levine
and it's basically going into the body
finding the source of trauma and seeing
if you can localize it in the body like
I said for me it's in my solar plexus
making a connection with that part of
the body because again as the body is a
reference of the unconscious mind
if the unconscious traumas are stored
there it's manifest in a certain part of
the body and we can use that part of the
body to kind of reverse engineer and get
back into those unconscious programs the
unconscious programs that are running
the anxiety in the first place
so that's one thing the other thing is
it's called Parts work internal family
systems it's a therapy uh that that
really takes your background and says
okay so for me when I was in grade three
I was bullied quite a bit in grade three
so there's part of me there's a bullied
part in me and then there's a part of me
that protects that Bully part and it
protects that Bully part by being hyper
Vigilant by worrying by trying to
control my environment so internal
family systems work says okay can I talk
and this is getting woo I realize it but
it makes a difference it really has
helped me and it's helped so many people
but it's like can I talk to the part
that's protecting the bullied part this
is where it gets a little complex but
really what we're doing is we're we're
dicing down into where is the trauma
really
like where is this trauma that's being
held in our system and we can divide it
up into like The Bully part the part the
the part that was ignored the part that
wasn't protected you know I see women
who were abused by a family member and
their mother didn't believe them you
know so all these parts start coming up
and then when we use the body as a way
of kind of tracking back into the root
cause of the unconscious mind rather
than just talking to it it's kind of
like talking to someone through through
a door you know they can generally get
your tone to voice they know roughly
what you're talking about but you're not
making any real changes
so I believe a combination of somatic
therapy uh internal family systems
therapy that's what's really helped me a
lot and of course I mean the
psychedelics
helped me understand the root cause of
where my anxiety came from in the first
place which is the state of alarm that's
held in my body that I call Background
alarm because it's alarmed it's not
resolved that comes from your background
and until we resolve that engine that's
creating the anxiety in the first place
through interception
we don't we can we can cope but we don't
heal and that's why some of my posts are
with like cognitive therapies it'll help
you cope absolutely and and I'm a big
fan of cognitive therapies in a lot of
ways but unless you go back in unless
you make friends with that part of you
that was bullied or abused or abandoned
when you were a child and this is where
it gets woo I agree but again what does
science really given us in the
therapeutic model that's made a big
difference not a lot so I'm I'm
straddling that as you said earlier I'm
straddling this set of you know
Neuroscience medicine thing with this
kind of woo okay healing comes from this
interpersonal connection and it's been
that way for 50 years real healing comes
from your interpersonal connection with
your therapist and your family and
learning how to connect with yourself
because if you can't connect with
yourself if you're split from yourself
your relationships are always going to
be transactional I've been married three
times you know I wanted to say this
earlier on I've been married three times
the last last time Cynthia who's a
symmetrauma therapist there wasn't a
whole lot of Sparks at the front there
wasn't a whole lot of oh my God oh my
God oh my God
um but there was this sense of just this
this is the right person for me like
this is really and I'm not sure if I was
just exhausted because I was like 50 at
the time or whatever but it's just like
this this is the right person for me and
we get into this environment where it's
like oh because my previous
relationships have all been like oh my
God this is amazing and and the whole uh
Cascade of oxytocin and all that kind of
stuff it just it just numbs your brain
out to see there's a lot of red flags
here you know and this is this isn't a
place that you really want to go so this
has been the most comfortable rewarding
relationship I've ever been in and I
think that comes from just knowing
myself and knowing yes the the the the
women who are a little bit off balance
there's a real I have a real draw to
those women absolutely because I want to
heal them or fix them or whatever I want
to do but I also know now using my
prefrontal cortex that's probably not
the best thing you know if you're out
for a dinner with someone on like a
bumble date or whatever it is and they
drink a bottle of wine at dinner
probably a red flag but because she's so
pretty I'm just gonna ignore that like I
just I'm just gonna let it go by the
spots can hide an awful lot of uh
discontent and problems below that
without a doubt and I think that's true
with men I think men I think we are much
more susceptible to fall into that
addiction habit women because they have
that language reference because they're
able to talk to talk to their friends
about issues they have a bit of a valve
release they have a bit but we don't as
men typically so we have to find our own
way and we're also trained to be you
know the masters of our own destiny we
don't share our problems and I think
that that just builds up and builds up
and builds up and unless we develop the
emotional language and the ability
mostly just to connect with that boy who
didn't have a father or was abused by a
father or had a mother that was
inundating you know just connecting with
that child going back and finding him as
woo as that sounds it's really been the
critical feature in my own healing
coming from a medical doctor and
neuroscientist yeah I mean I've used
medicine and Neuroscience as much as I
can but it really comes down to how much
of a connection can you make with
yourself and specifically that younger
version of yourself because he is still
in there she is still in there and and I
think one of the reasons why anxiety is
such a motivational state is because he
or she the child in you is like hey we
want attention and what we're going to
do is we're going to force alarm through
your system until you get the message
unfortunately men often don't get the
message and they live their whole lives
in this quiet desperation
for all that I can have my concerns
about woo and stuff like that one of the
most recent trips I took on psilocybin
which was just a mild dose nothing crazy
uh maybe halfway through something like
that I had this vision of myself as a
child and I had a bit of a rough
childhood with bullying in school and
feeling lonely he was an only child as
well so I was kind of socially Outcast
and and isolated uh and sort of looked
at this child as myself and realized
probably I I
rationally realized it and logically
realized it before but for the first
time I ever felt it emotionally that
that child deserved sympathy that I felt
sorry for that child I felt proud of the
fact that he'd been able to go through
the things that he'd gone through I felt
um like I wanted to protect him like I
should be proud of him uh and and mostly
like he deserved sympathy whereas
previously I'd felt shame or
embarrassment about the fact that I'd
even though you don't choose the things
that you go through as a child
um maybe there was shame around the fact
that I know that other people had worse
things happen to them just than like a
lot of bullying
um you know I wasn't sexually abused by
a parent like what have I got to whine
about I think that's another part of the
male coping strategy that was so adverse
some of us are so averse to a victim
mentality that we will bear more
responsibility than we need to a lot of
the time uh and yeah I looked at this
version of myself sat in front of the
the drawers in my old bedroom back in
Newcastle and I'm looking at it and I'm
thinking
like I should really really feel sorry
for you like if I knew a child that was
going through that now I'd go up to them
and I'd say come here like I'd want to
give them a hug I'd want to tell them
they were awesome I'd want them to feel
secure and safe and and like they belong
and like they're competent and capable
uh and that was the first time that I'd
ever felt that so you know for all that
my woo radar is concerned about about
that I and I I also agree with you that
it seems like in a a better help or one
of the sponsors of this show I think
that the therapy that they do is
fantastic and almost everybody could
benefit from working with a licensed
professional counselor and yet there
seems to be an upper bound with some of
the strategies that people go through
you know CBT I had Donald Robertson on
this stoicism and CBT guys phenomenal
um and CBT really really successful at
dealing with stuff but
it still does feel like there is maybe a
little bit of a ceiling that people can
won't break through and I wonder whether
um you know a combination of a more
holistic
um internal family systems approach the
somatic stuff uh to open yourself up I
mean when you think about what you're
doing with uh MDMA Psychotherapy right
like what are you doing there it's
that's just a rocket boosted equivalent
I'm going to guess at the somatic stuff
like what you're doing with the somatic
stuff is uh maybe uh
endogenously being able to get yourself
into a state that MDMA may exogenously
be able to assist you in getting into I
don't know yeah I mean I think what MDMA
does is just makes you feel this love
you know and I think so much so many of
us that grew up with trauma don't allow
that love it
because it wasn't safe like we have this
feeling like the rug's gonna get pulled
out from under us you know there's no
point especially when I see people who
have like say an alcoholic parent
and it goes along fine for a while and
then it blows up and then it goes along
fine for a while and then it blows up so
what their nervous system realizes is
like I don't want to be vulnerable
because when I'm vulnerable and it blows
up it's just way too painful for me so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
keep myself with this hyper and brene
brown talks about this to keep myself in
this hyper vigilant kind of level all
the time so when things do blow up I
don't feel quite so discombobulated but
basically what you're doing is you're
living your life at a three out of ten
the whole time because the drop to a two
isn't nearly as painful if you allow
yourself to live at a six or a seven and
then it drops to a two that's
excruciating especially when you have
trauma as a child because uncertainty is
so abhorrent to us so we try and make
life more certain the other thing is you
know the child in this holds you know if
you're a bullied as a child as I was you
know holds a lot of Shame so there's the
adult in us that's like I don't want to
go back and visit that child because
he's in a lot of pain right and the
childness is saying well you know
holding up their hands like you said
like can you pick me up and you're going
uh you're too painful for me to pick up
so this is the Paradox right so this is
this is basically the bridge that you
have to cross to be able to actually
fully heal yourself rather than just
learn how to cope and the little analogy
that I draw is like you're in a rowboat
there's a hole in the bottom of the rope
and it's filling up with water now you
can bail water out of that you can you
can do a lot of cognitive strategies
that will help you kind of gratitude
reformulate a lot of this stuff but in
the end you're always baling water
now going underneath and actually
patching that hole in the boat going
back finding that child finding the true
source of alarm metabolizing it allowing
it to be there embracing the uncertainty
of it and embracing that child in us as
woo as this sounds patches that hole in
the boat so we don't need to today
anymore and that's the thing with me is
like people said are you anxiety free
it's like no I'm not anxiety free I
still get alarmed but I don't give it
the same credibility that I used to and
on top of that I think the biggest tip
that I could give anybody is when you
are alarmed anxious whatever you want to
call it just allow it to be there in
your body as opposed to compulsively
going up into your head because as soon
as you go up into your head you've lost
the battle because basically that's an
endless loop that you'll never get out
of the only way and vessel vanico talks
about this too is acclimatizing to that
sense of alarm now some people have
severe pain you know abuse emotional
physical sexual abuse and you don't want
to do this alone but in general our
traumas like you said you know are are
kind of manageable if we don't add
thoughts to it when we start adding
thoughts to it then it becomes a runaway
train it's kind of like when people come
in to see me about panic attacks people
will describe like I felt really
lightheaded I felt really weird I felt
really strange
um for like three or four minutes and
then it seemed to resolve and then what
happens is they'll have that same
sensation and they'll go oh my God I
wonder if I'm having a heart attack or I
wonder if I'm having a stroke now once
they once the thought goes in and this
is exactly what I'm trying to get at so
you have this alarm in your system you
know dopamine epinephrine the whole
system lights up and then you start
going oh it's a heart attack so then you
believe that it's a heart attack because
that makes it a little more certain and
then the whole Cascade starts whereas if
you can just bring in that alarm and
allow it to be there and embrace it and
that's what I tell I have a video on my
YouTube channel about when you start
feeling a panic attack bring it on this
make it the best freaking panic attack
you've ever had like say that's and I do
that I say okay bring it on because that
takes the locus of control away from the
panic attack to me even though it's
going to happen to me anyway I still
tell myself this is good this is going
to be me taking control of the panic and
all just taking in control of the panic
itself you being in charge to say okay
bring it on let's go
alleviates it because what happens with
panic is that it builds and it builds
it's like no no no no no no no no no no
and it gets stronger and stronger and
stronger until you can't let it so of
course it's going to hit you like a ton
of bricks but if you as soon as you feel
it coming on and I've had panic attacks
so I know what happens and I know the
feeling I get when it's starting it's
sort of like oh my brain goes a little
spacey it's like okay let's do this now
let's go and there's parts of our brain
called the periaqueductal gray which
basically secretes endogenous and your
your own morphine and dopamine and and
those things both kind of help you
metabolize when you start leaning into
your worries and leaning into your fears
your brain will come up and support you
with those chemicals now if you start
going back on your heels your brain will
also support that so it supports you in
growth and it supports you in protection
the problem is most of us with anxiety
go into a victim mentality and when we
get into victim mentality we secrete
nothing but epinephrine and cortisol
which of course self-reinforces this
fact that a we can't get into our
prefrontal cortex and B we can't soothe
ourselves because we're doing more of
the things that's actually causing us
the pain in the first place which is
overthinking
Russell I really really like your work
man I think that you've got a fantastic
demeanor about you that sort of clinical
with the the holistic I very very much
appreciate I love how peaceful you are
as well uh where should people go if
they want to check out your YouTube and
the other stuff that you do online where
should they head the anxiety MD like
that's all my that's my website that's
uh my Instagram the not the anxiety
doctor the anxiety MD and that's the
easiest easiest way to find me and then
my book is on Amazon it's called
anxietyrx it's uh it's funny you know
this book uh took two years to sell 10
000 copies and in the last eight weeks
it sold 15 000 copies so it's really
starting to get so I really appreciate
Chris I can't tell you how much I
appreciate being on your show and being
able to expand my work because my my
goal is to have people not have to
suffer with anxiety the way I did for 30
years that's my goal and and I and I
take a bit of what happened with my dad
and I take that into my own life because
if I can take that pain that I suck
offered with him and sublimate that and
translate that into something that's
positive for everyone that's really what
I want to do I really want to get this
message out to people that a combination
of somatic maybe a little woo and
cognitive therapy is really what finally
gets you over the hill or past that
ceiling as you say so thanks again
Russell I really appreciate you thanks
mate thanks what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]